I think he might shut up cuz he does not
have that much money one time on this
program I gave the women of The View
Credit today is not that day every time
we say something that is mistaken 5
million people come down on you need to
correct that yes I would like the judge
to say you know what d
d I think from now on every time you
disparage or run over some other law
that we've gag order we've put into it's
GNA cost you $10
million think I just have that whoop
well because I feel like he thinks $510
million $10,000 doesn't mean anything
510 and so he just keeps doing it but if
you had to put your hand in your pocket
and five find a quick 10 million I think
he might shut
up cuz he does not have that much M deep
in his pocket he does not have I don't
think he has that much money I think we
should find out come on
[Applause]
Jud